summerslam coming up at allegiant
stadium let's talk a little bit about
the match so you're taking on jinder
mahal and for those who may be a little
behind on their wwe history there's a
lot of store backstory here you two were
a member of a group called 3mb you were
both you both part of ways with the wwe
jinder made a big comeback won the world
title you made a big comeback won the
world title but it's interesting right
because there is at least this
perception from some fans about your
rise versus his rise
some people being critical of his
in-ring skills and i know you've talked
in the past about how you plan as with
all your opponents really showcasing how
good jinder mahal really is but i wanted
to know considering your friendship do
you feel perhaps more of a sense of
responsibility than usual to make sure
that people come out of this not
realizing just how good you are but how
good he is
maybe um subconsciously i want to make
sure just because how close we are and
we both come out looking as good as
possible but i look at that wave that
way for every single match i mean it
doesn't matter who i'm in the ring with
i want to make sure people leave saying
wow
that was a lot better than i thought it
was going to be hopefully they go in
thinking this is going to be good but
for some reason if they have it in their
head perhaps like on monday night raw
when i've been wrestling with the
genders associates veer and shanky have
very limited experience it's my
responsibility uh to make sure that
people watch that match and go oh well
okay these guys have got something we
highlight the positives perhaps
hide the negatives a little bit and with
the match with gender i'm excited to
show just how much he's grown over the
past few years when he won the title it
was a huge opportunity i do think he did
a good job with it but it came out of
nowhere and i think that's why nobody
really accepted it to the level they've
accepted mine he's grown so much in the
ring over the years but also
confidence-wise and thinking as a
top-level performer-wise and we're going
to show that for sure it's saturday at
summerslam
you know i imagine when someone wins the
wwe title they're getting a lot of texts
and phone calls from friends and family
do you remember any conversations
between you and jinder and the aftermath
of your wins or even just sort of
reflecting on the road to this match
about
you know where you guys were and where
you are now
yeah just talking about how crazy
things are now perhaps we make jokes
about if only we had this mindset 3mb
when we were out partnering and drinking
and living the gimmick all the time is
we're fake rock stars we're acting like
real at rock stars out the ring if we
got our stuff together and started
working out and having this positive
attitude we have now it could have been
done sooner but i see as it could have
been the journey happens for a reason
all the ups and downs made us who we are
today and we can laugh and joke about it
now but we both are very fortunate happy
and proud and we've been able to get to
the level where we're facing each other
on this huge show with saturday at
summerslam this is this year's
wrestlemania a.m is summerslam and it's
going to be wild over 40 000 people
losing their minds and the fact that i'm
facing one of my best friends is pretty
crazy
now without getting anyone into any
trouble are there any fun stories on the
road rockstar experiences that you're
willing to share
it's like most of the stuff that we got
to i wish i could forget
it was wild i guess you do that in your
20s
but yeah it was just a lot of nights i
love
being a kid um and a lot of uh
growing up that had to be done and
thankfully during both our times away
from wwe we had a hard look at ourselves
in the mirror and knew we had to make
some changes and thankfully both of us
made those positive changes
and we encourage people today as a list
and sometimes you can make silly
mistakes and
and during that time i was also going
through a lot of personal issues i kind
of was at some dark places i was in
you know some difficult places it didn't
even seem like a light at the end of the
tunnel but i tell everyone out there
trust me no matter how dark the times
get there's always a light at the end of
the turn you just gotta keep believing
you've got to keep fighting you've got
to cut the negative stuff out your life
and trust me you'll get there
and i know you talked to my uh colleague
carlos bustamante a few months ago about
it so if anyone's interested in hearing
more about drew's story we have that on
the channel as well i've heard you talk
about this old thing oh don't worry we
are going to plug that
i have it on the list
um
you know hearing you talk about the
story with gender as as well as plans
you hope to have you know opposite
sheamus at wrestlemania and when even
when we talk about sort of your like
redemption arc
in the wwe maybe i'm picking up on stuff
that isn't there but it feels like
you're particularly passionate when
these stories playing out in wwe reflect
at least in part your own life your real
relationships with some of these guys so
i wanted to ask you for drew mcintyre
what is the recipe to a great wwe
storyline
like you say making it as real as
possible if it's real to you if you can
invest in if you believe in it 100 it's
going to come across to the fans and
they're going to feel it and
that's always been the case throughout
history like i always no matter how the
storyline is even if it's not based in
reality i'll try and find something
that's true to me so i can focus on the
truth and bring the truth to the story
but if it can be 100 legitimate if we
can lean into real stories if we can
make people feel like well this i know
the rest of it i don't know about that
but this is real for example like john
cena and roman reigns last week on the
microphone but they're going at each
other hard they're hitting each other
with lines that perhaps the other
person's not expecting because they want
to make people think oh my goodness
they're going off on each other right
now this is real the rest i don't know
but they're really going at each other
for real in that microphone and that's
going to make me more invested in the
match and the story and that's what it's
all about in the end is making the fans
say i have to see this
since you brought up roman reigns and
john cena and their trash talk i know at
times in the wwe perhaps more of the on
microphone stuff is written by a
creative team i know sometimes it's a
little more off the cuff by the wrestler
sometimes it's a good marriage of the
two uh what's your promo
preparation like is it more
improvisation the things you want to do
with talking points or do you work very
closely with the scripting team
i think the best um is the marriage of
both that you mentioned like i think if
you read it off the paper and that's on
you you should not just take somebody's
words and try and recite them word for
word because it's not going to be real
it's going to come across fake people
are gonna see it in your tone in your
eyes and if they don't feel it well you
might as well just you're just wasting
tv time and wasting your opportunity if
you're able to work with the writer get
your voice you've got to stay within the
confines of the story you can't just go
out there just do whatever you want go
to business for yourself and not match
the storyline you're in you do have to
match what you're doing that week
whatever the long-term goal is so you
get your rider okay this is a story this
is we're trying to get to this is we're
trying to convey tonight for me
personally once i know that much i get
an idea in my head i'll perhaps have a
finish and ideally i like to go out
there and just kind of see how the crowd
are responding i'm very interactive i
like to go back and forth with the
audience and sometimes i'll do stuff
that people go oh obviously they planned
that and uh whatever they never like
this week on raw for example i did a
thing where i had raised my hand and i
had everyone raised their hand with me
like who thinks tinder is going to win
and i've looked around who thinks drew's
going to win and everyone raised their
hands with me like serbia says you're
screwed i knew i was going to get to you
are screwed i didn't know i was going to
do the hand thing it just felt right
when i was out there and i love having
that back and forth for the fans so much
i think people will be surprised how
little was planned sometimes on a
microphone i love it now as we begin to
wrap up here
when you know we were talking to wwe
about setting this up and they said we
have drew available i thought to myself
of course they have drew available i've
seen this room many times because drew
mcintyre is a media machine and this is
amazing this is a newer background
actually
i've been on this one for about four
weeks that probably means i've done
about 400 interviews exactly
and you you talked about how for you
it's very important to become this
representation for the company this
ambassador and that's why you've been
taking on so many of these press
opportunities and got and it got me
thinking i know you get asked all the
time um what advice do you have for
wrestlers coming up but i want to sort
of tweak that a bit what advice would
you give to other wwe superstars that
have nothing to do with your in-ring
performance or your character just on
the you know overall scale of what it
means to be a wwe superstar
i would say just learn as much as you
possibly can and take advantage of every
opportunity you're given like i see
stuff like this when i talk about the
interviews this isn't work because it's
never been worked it's my entire life
stream to a part wwe if i get a chance
to talk about myself talk about wwe
represent the company that's a dream and
for the newer superstars any chance you
get push people hey is there a little
interview here i can do a little local
market there get the reps in and prove
yourself outside the ring because one
day when you get that big chance on tv
you're going to get the big chance for
the interviews you have to be ready you
have to be able to represent yourself in
the company in a correct manner and
remember it's not a freaking job this is
literally the easiest thing in the world
because it's it should be like a fantasy
we're living right now that's how i feel
i talk to my friends back in scotland
they're working real jobs they're nine
to five they put the work in and they're
really hard working admire them for it
this is a dream so do what you can to
improve yourself outside the ring you
get more opportunities and then you get
to do the really cool stuff like when i
get to do the charity work or do the
children's hospital visits or the
make-a-wish or special olympics we start
getting the chance to do that stuff then
you're like this is what it's all about
the in-ring stuff's cool but there's so
much more outside the ring that's
beautiful the last thing here and i want
to sort of tie it into of course where
et canada tied into the bigger
entertainment sphere a little bit now
you know if you look at like strict
television ratings perhaps pro wrestling
right now isn't it like the same sheer
level of popularity that it was in let's
say the late late 90s early early 2000s
but i actually think there's a healthier
relationship between
the wwe and beyond and hollywood because
when you look at some of the mainstream
stars we now have john cena dave
bautista the rock all
legitimately talented and appreciated
actors who can still come back to wwe in
the same vein you have shows like heels
glow that are celebrating the history of
pro wrestling
for you having done so much media
especially now how do you think
wrestling is perceived in the bigger
entertainment sphere compared to perhaps
20 years ago
um i mean it's interesting that you say
and the ratings wise i never really get
into that because tv's so different now
all the time platforms etc the wwe still
top of the cable basically every week
but yeah the difference now the respect
level i think wrestling is seen a lot
more differently than it used to be it's
not seen as the low brow form of
entertainment people used to look down
on people understand now that wwe is a
huge global company they have 800
million homes 180 countries 20 different
languages over a billion social media
followers and some of our talent are
good out there outside the company
proving how talented their performers
are like we look at rock unbelievable a
top paid a hollywood actor made billions
of dollars in his movies has his own
company and he mentioned cena's
branching out now batista like he's the
one that surprised me almost mostly so
quiet in real life but he went out there
he worked on his craft and he's a
genuinely good actor and he takes it so
seriously and they've shown like
wrestles are capable of so much more
than just
everyone's perception big dumb meat
heads if you take a time to look at most
of our roster everyone's basically got a
degree we've got a few phds i have a
criminology degree we're all educate
these days so if you take a second but
look at it you realize oh they're not
just big dumb meatheads they're actually
talented in many ways
um
last last thing if you were to make the
jump into the world of acting is there a
particular genre that would excite you
the most action horror etcetera
have a big horror film
i wanted to have a whole talk on horror
movies and exchange lists we'll have to
save it for next time yeah i'm always
pitching like if they ever remake
braveheart like braveheart 2 because you
know batista's got his new zombie movie
zombies are still the rage i was like
all right if they end up brave fart
william wallace got killed he was hung
drawn and quartered his body parts were
spread across the uk's head and london
bridge somebody takes his body parts
puts them back together he rises up as
zombie wallace and wreaks havoc on the
english and braveheart 2 the rise of
wallace
what a pitch
what an amazing you put a lot of thought
into this oh it's been through my head
for a while but i joked about it first
knowing actually that could work